now so you joined the military uh got
weapons training uh and have been trying
to save lives as a medic uh and I think
at some point they realized that uh you
had enormous talents uh in terms of
public awareness and Communications uh
and thinking and writing what is the
American public missing like are are
there things that are happening on the
ground uh that uh would surprise folks
who just tune into mainstream news
coverage yes and there's a big one and
it's refrain that the American public
oftentimes hears but it's something that
I would love for them all to see and I'm
trying to create a program where it's
called hello Ukraine and I spoke to you
briefly about that where we would bring
people over to see what's really
happening there's been no greater return
on investment than what the U.S tax
dollars are going towards in Ukraine in
the last 80 years of foreign policy and
yet what they would need to see is how
much more we need
giving us little Drip by Drip by drip of
of sourcing of weapons humanitarian Aid
and civilian Aid is it great and we're
appreciative but at the same point we
could end this war in one to two months
if we were able to get everything on the
wish list now and so sometimes it feels
like we're fighting as an Insurgent Army
even though we're fighting with the best
weapons
yeah yeah we're defending it and we're
making do with in ways that NATO
standard troops could never imagine
and there's a great Point that's in a
congressional research paper
where it was talking about amphibious
vehicles for the United States Marine
Corps
the United States has learned so much
about Russian weaknesses that we've been
able to in the United States modify some
of our thinking based on what the
Ukrainian armed forces have been able to
carry out here what we're doing here
with U.S tax dollars is advancing U.S
knowledge in the areas of defense and
Warfare by decades versus what they
would be learning in simulations and so
what I could tell the U.S taxpayers is
your support is not going to waste and
if you could just stay with us and tell
your Congress people to get us the
weapons we need all of them right now
we will end this war and Destroy Russia
as a threat forever that's a very
powerful message and something that uh
our lawmakers need to hear I will say uh
I 100 believe that any investment to
support Ukrainian defense is has a
better Roi than anything else that we
could be doing uh if you imagine another
world where Russia were to steamroll
Ukraine uh I think about the costs of
that world not just in human cause which
are the obvious ones but but also of the
message it sends to China and others who
might consider various aggressive uh
acts
um and then the reverse that if you can
remove Russia as a global threat uh that
would be
Monumental uh historic and uh it's more
a product of Ukrainian courage and
sacrifice obviously than anything that
uh is being sent to the country by the
American government how would you
describe the Ukrainian people from your
nearly year there I've never been around
a group of people
more certain in their beliefs
and more willing to carry them out than
the Ukrainian people you talk about
morale of course the morale waxes and
wanes because we're surrounded by Death
but no one has lost the belief in
Victory and this has been amazing they
talk about folks in the west being tired
of of the conflict
people are tired here but they are still
fully energized and fully focused on
winning and so I become inspired
it doesn't even have to be at the front
lines I could be in the middle of the
country and I see somebody living in
darkness and become inspired by them
knowing that they are chopping firewood
when they were living with electricity
two weeks ago chopping fire would just
stay warm and not complaining they're
going forward ready and willing to
sacrifice in whatever way
not just militarily in order to find
Victory and liberate their country and
that's I think one of the greatest
Follies that people are making
is trying to compare this to any other
foreign intervention by the United
States uh in the last 80 years because
ultimately this is an ally
who has been invaded on their territory
has had a what was known at one time as
the second greatest army in the world we
now know the Russian army is is really
worthless and useless except to carry
out terrorism
and so
this conflict this war this battle
in no way can be judged by anything
that's happened since World War II
and the Ukrainian people are fighting it
as if it was a World War because you
have Iranian drones coming in at them
you have North Korean armaments coming
in at them you have Belarus and Russia
launching attacks at us or Russia
launching attacks from Belarusian
territory at us and so ultimately you
have these different countries that are
all coming at Ukraine
and it's the Ukrainian people that are
standing strong against this tyranny and
against these tyrants you are an
American uh risking your life in Ukraine
I admire you a great deal as I'm sure
anyone listening to this does
um are there people from around the
world who are showing up in Ukraine you
just described kind of the uh assemblage
of forces against uh Ukraine
um has there been a similar rally on the
other side absolutely
there's a core group of and and for
security reasons I can't say the number
there's a core group of
fighters who have come over willing to
sign contracts not as mercenaries we
don't have mercenaries here people who
are signing contracts directly with the
Ukrainian Armed Forces fighting on
behalf of Ukraine taking this oath to
defend Ukraine not giving up their
belief in their Nation I'm very proud to
be from the United States and the United
States is my my home but we are choosing
to sign up and and pledge our honor and
our courage to Ukraine in order to fight
back against this worldwide tyranny and
so ultimately you have it in the
military and then you have this
tremendous tremendous outpouring of
people who have come over as civilian
volunteers from places such as Canada
the Baltic countries you have uh great
people coming from the United States
from Australia and so the civilian
volunteer network be it through
Logistics be it through supplies or even
through Hands-On Medical work is really
something that is humbling to know how
these people are risking their lives for
this fight for freedom
[Music]